字幕: Naoko Hirami
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は 30年間ぐらい
エレベータ技術者の仕事をしてきました
エレベータはこういうものです
みなさんが日常的に
よく使っているものですけど
実はエレベータには
ちょっとした秘密があります
エレベータは 世界一安全な乗り物です
これは アメリカの統計ですけど
日本も似たような感じです
一番下の段は 車の死亡者数ですね
それと比べてエレベータは
ほとんど人に害のない乗り物です
毎日何百万人が世界中で使ってるけど
全然故障しません
落ちません
でもその 落ちないということは
決して自然なことではないです
どういうことかというと
今映っている 暗い長い空洞の上に
エレベータのカゴが 細いワイヤーロープに
ぶら下がって保たれているんです
それが安全に動くようにするためには
エレベータ技術者が
そこに技術を蓄えているんです
例えば ロープが切れない 滑らない
絶対に故障しないような構造にしています
非常に素晴らしいものです
この素晴らしいものを
私は過去15年間
ぶっ壊そうと思っています
なぜでしょう？
非常に安全で 効率良くて
現在の都会生活を支えている
働き者ですけど
それでもやっぱり次の世代のエレベータを
作らないといけないと 私は思っています
まずひとつ 技術者として感じた話をします
これが
高層建物の中にエレベータが
入っている配置図みたいなものですが
エレベータはそれぞれが
自分のための空洞の中で —
「昇降路」と呼んでいるものですけど —
そこで上下している
で この絵のように
例えば 低い方の階と
高い方の階に行くエレベータが
それぞれ別に分かれて動いています
しかし仮に
それぞれのエレベータ１台ずつじゃなくて
複数台が同じところで走れるようになれば
大きな面積が
もっと有効に活用できるようになります
これで 都会の生活は
飛躍的に変わると思います
今 建物の中に …
空洞だらけの建物の中に
もっと人とか物とが入れるようになります
しかしこれは
現在のエレベータでは 不可能です
現在のエレベータは
ロープで吊らされている以上
同じところに複数のカゴは走らない
そういう構造です
こういうことを実現するためには
新しいエレベータが必要です
それが リニアモータのような
もので動くエレベータです
それが私の夢です
で ここまでの話は
技術者としてのことですけど
実はもうひとつ —
ひょっとしたらもっと大きな理由もあります
都会の 風景を思い出して下さい
私も実は 言われるまで
気がつかなかったんですけど
建物は ほとんど四角い立方体の箱です
ものすごい単調な風景です
なぜ 建物が箱型になるんですか？
なぜ 丸い建物とか曲がった建物が
できないですか？
その理由は 建築上の制約条件とかではなくて
やっぱり エレベータです
今のエレベータは ロープで吊らされて
垂直に動くものですから
そのエレベータの垂直の軌道の周りに
建物が立っているような感じです
つまり今のエレベータでは
建物の中は 空洞だらけになって
非常に効率の悪い構造に
なっているだけでなくて
さらにその建物は
こういう箱型にしかできないです
これに気がついて
私たち技術者に挑戦状を突き出したのは
高松伸先生です
建築家です
彼がこのような
輪っか型の建物を建てようと思って
しかし それは今のエレベータではできません
エレベータ技術者に
「この夢の建物が作れるように
新しいエレベータを作って下さい」
と依頼しました
仮に この建物を走る —
例えばこのような カプセル型の
エレベータができたとしたら
こういう輪っか型の建物も
もちろんできます
でもそれだけじゃなくて
例えばアーチ型の建物
その下のスペースをまた別に使えるような
新しい構造物ができる
あるいは もう本当に建築家の創造次第で
どんな建物でもできます
こういうメビウス曲線状の建物とか
本当に夢みたいなものができます
このような新しい建物が並ぶ
そういう新しい都会 そういう新しい風景
やっぱりここで 日本で
ひょっとしたら神戸で作りましょう
これは今は夢話に聞こえるんですが
実は技術が進んで
技術的には
ほぼできるようになってきたんです
しかしそこまできたら 今度は
技術でない新しい問題に
立ち向かうことになりました
ちょっと今の図を見て下さい
左側が 従来のエレベータ
ロープで吊らされて そのロープに
ぶら下がっているカゴが上下します
それに対して
リニアモータエレベータは
地上側に電気を流す
長いモータがあって
そこに磁力で引っつけられて上下する
エレベータのカゴがあります
さて ちょっと直感的な質問ですけど
この私の夢のエレベータに乗りますか？
（客席 拍手）
（笑）
乗らないと思いますね
怖いでしょう？
（客席 笑）
「停電でもしたら 落下するじゃないか」と
「本当に安心で安全で乗れるか」と
これははっきり言って誤解です
まず その誤解を解くためには
ちょっとだけ 技術的な話をします
この左側の従来型のエレベータは
カゴは何で支えてるんでしょうか？
ま ロープと思われると思いますね
それがまず誤解です
ロープはあくまでもモータの中の磁力を
カゴに伝えるための道具 —
力を与えるための部品にすぎないです
ロープで支えているのではなくて
モータの中の磁場で支えています
それは リニアモータエレベータと
何も変わらないです
リニアモータにも同じく
今のエレベータと同じ安全装置 —
機械的なブレーキとか
万が一落下したときの衝撃を
吸収するバッファとか
そういうのはつけましょうと
そしたら 従来のエレベータも磁力で支えて
今の新しいリニアモータエレベータも
磁力で支えられるんですけど
そこでもうひとつ ちょっとつけ加えます
ちょっとした実験をします
これが磁石です
この磁石は 電気がなくなった時は
このように落下すると思われると思いますね
しかし実際は何が起きるかと —
相手側が金属で これがアルミですけど
（磁石がゆっくり落ちる）
こういうことが起きます
これが 磁石です
鉄だったら ひっつきますが
アルミだったら？
あるいは 銅体だったら
（ゆっくり落ちる）
このような ゆっくりとした
静かなスピードで落ちてくるんです
これは実は
今からお見せする リニアモータでも
同じような現象があります
これが 普通に上下できる仕掛けです
今度 上がったところで
停電になりました
さあ どうなるでしょう？
停電になっても さっきと同じ原理で
エレベータが静かに
ゆっくりと降りていきます
つまり従来のエレベータと同等か
それ以上の安全性を持っています
これまでの話で ひょっとしたら
まだ納得行かれていない方も
いるかもしれないですが
これからちょっとだけ
従来のエレベータの悪口をします
（笑）
まずこの従来のエレベータのロープが
このモータの方に 溝の中で 引っ掻かれて
そこで発生する摩擦力で引っ張られます
もちろん 溝も ロープも 摩擦力も全部
きれいにきっちりと設計されて
常時メンテナンスされて
滑らないようにはできてるんです
しかしそのメンテナンスを怠った場合や
万が一 手を抜いたときは
やっぱり滑る危険が 常にあります
さらに ロープ自体も寿命があります
ロープを何年かに一度
点検の上で交換する必要があるんですが
それもまた メンテナンスが
おろそかになった場合は
危険を及ぼします
もうひとつ
エレベータにロープが取りつけられている —
「ヒッチ」と呼んでいるところですが
そこも 滅多にはないですけど
万が一 問題が起きることがないとは
言い切れないです
つまり言いたいのは
リニアモータエレベータと
従来のエレベータを比較すると
両方とも 同じく
我々を支えているのは磁力です
しかし 従来のエレベータだったら
その力と カゴの間に
余計な部品がたくさん入っています
その余計な部品は もちろん
きれいに設計されて メンテナンスされて
常に安全に動いているんですよ
最初に紹介した実績からも分かるように
しかしどっちかと言うと
余計な物がない方が良いじゃないですか？
そういう危険が わずかであっても
それがさらに少ない方が
私は優れていると思います
このリニアモータエレベータが
もし実現すれば
もし みなさんが それを支持して
「私は乗ります」っていう気持ちになれば
これからの都会が
飛躍的に変わってきます
今の単調な風景から
今映っているような
本当に夢の近未来の都会に変身します
しかし そこに行くためには
もはや技術ではなくて社会の意識 —
みなさんの「これを使ってみようか」
と思う気持ち
それが必要となります
そこに誤解があれば
我々技術者がいくら「これが良い」と
言ってもそこまでです
ということで このお話を聞いたみなさん
ちょっと持ち帰って 少し考えて下さい
ありがとうございました
（拍手）